you
hi everyone is cherry here's another
cool endgame study this one from 1951
composed by Joseph Hasek a Czech study
composer it's white to move as usual I
encourage you to pause the video see if
you can find the best continuation for
right
okay now for the typical clever solution
night and g4 that's a fort the night
must be captured the idea behind this
move is to lock up the position create
another instance of fixed pons pons that
can't move doing something other than
that
well eventually now there can be some
pawn break h4 the position will open up
the queen will be able to enter one way
or the other maybe along the G file with
H form or coming in along this diagonal
so this is the first key idea Knight g4
he must be captured and now a further
closing up of the position locking down
with d4 that's a check doesn't matter
where the King goes and here is the last
phase the last idea
once we've acquired this position where
we have it completely locked it doesn't
get much more a lock than this all
instances of fixed pawns on board 8 vs 8
what to do from here let me just show
you one faulty attempt and that is just
some type of passing move rook to d1
black is able to make progress how well
there is one way to enter the white
position and that's what the Queen is
heading for and what do you do exactly
I mean there's no way to stop the Queen
from getting to one of these squares and
something's going to fall soon the f2
pawn the h2 pawn I don't know just as an
example something like this the h2 pawn
is gonna fall soon and this guy I'll
push through so this isn't going to work
we need to be extra clever here and not
just make some silly Rick move to b1
what is the solution well this may look
silly but we'll see the idea behind it
rook h1 the key idea now let's see what
happens if
the black queen tries to enter along
this diagonal Queen h8 King e1 where is
he headed towards g1 why is he doing
this to smother the rook to make it so
that the rook has no legal moves in now
black cannot enter along this diagonal
successfully Queen here to try and pick
up the pawn well this is stalemate no
rook move no King move no pawn moves
clever and there's nothing more to
really try here I mean what does what
does black to you return the King all
you do is white it just bounce back and
forth and yeah there's not going to be
any progress
for example Queen b8 King f1 kingi one
Queen here right away another case of
stalemate so with the only other try is
maybe to play Queen to b5 giving white a
move you have to take the Queen but
white will go on to win white would be
there just in the nick of time
to get out of the rooks way the pawn
will be stopped in white would go on to
win but this is a this is another cool
one I like the initial start with
recognizing you have to lock down the
position somewhat otherwise the Queen
will be able to enter one way or the
other Knight g4 d4 pretty locked
position and then this last idea the
only way to combat the Queen from
entering successfully is to smother your
own rook rook h1 and then go to the G 1
square and this will hold easily as a
draw a fun one to test against your
favorite chess engine I know when I put
it against stockfish it was not able to
come up with the solution from the
initial position anyhow feel free to
share how you did with this one did you
get it let me know the comments section
below and as usual I hope you enjoyed it
that's all for now take
by
you